comment comment les gens ils arrivent à
deux vides et que je suis pieds noirs
ça c'est un mystère que j'arrive pas à
les lucides et j'arrive pas j'arrive pas
je n'arrive pas je sais bien qu'il
existe des clichés des légendes des
lieux combine contre lesquelles on peut
pas lutter c'est vrai on entend souvent
dire que les anglais sont gentleman que
les américains sont des grands enfants
que les écossais sont avares que les
allemands sont disciplinés que 6 ou sont
rusés caetera et caetera et caetera et
on dit aussi on dit que les corses
n'aime pas le travail en le dit enfin je
sais on le dit ah ben moi
jamais on m'a dit vous vous êtes corse
parce que moi je travaille je peux pas
le voir je ne peux pas le voir sion rur
du travail et vont revenir 1 je sais pas
si un jour j'ai déjà un gros je vois le
moins creed ravaille gpr avait à y loger
des boutons gg vraiment j'ai des
douleurs j'ai des douleurs j'aime pas
travail je sais pas si tout le monde il
est comme moi ça il ya trop de
responsabilités à le dire non non non
non je prendrais pas cet engagement mais
moi personnellement pour ce qui me
concerne j'aime pas le travail moi moi
mon rêve
si une place c'est une place par exemple
on va au bureau à 4h30 et on s'en va à
16h45 le lin ji en se souhaitant un bon
week end
voilà voilà c'est ça voilà troisièmes qu
on sabre et puis les vacances par un
mois des vacances un mois de vacances je
suis à voir ce que j'ai en moi c'est des
cons jugé dans les vacances toute
l'année on était la plage
en hiver la montagne de ski ou printemps
la campagne et en automne on se repose
on recharger les accus voilà voilà
noah s'est je vois voilà c'est ça que
jamais le travail j'aime pas chez
patients moi j'aime pourquoi je vais
m'en tire j'aime eh bien je n'aime pas
travailler jamais on m'a dit vous êtes
course à peine on me voit jeudi deux ou
trois mouches barbares comme ça me dit
oh là là mais vous vous êtes pieds noirs
comment les gens il
va deviner ça je comprends pas je
comprends pas c'est un mystère je
comprends pas encore un belge à 20 kg
mais on arrive à le repérer un beisel
mon chéri les belges et on en parle
épouvantable et belge ils ont un parent
né à rien s'il vous plaît vous voulez
vous une fois ils ont déboulé les frais
y travaillons mais s'il vous plaît venez
vous s'il vous pourriez en face à ces
belges tout craché il manque juste le
mal qu'on puisse réellement mon chéri le
mannequin spis vue à bruxelles
enfin je les ai vus il a fallu que je le
cherche parce que c'est pas les
pyramides la somme qui vous unit 4 comme
ça devienne juste auront un oeil
disposition leur tour eiffel et bon ami
ci-contre là dessus pour installer la
télévision avec les antennes la brème on
pas quand la moitié d'une chaîne
enfin les benchs est facile de les
reconnaître
mais moi comme les types il arrive à
reconnaître que je suis pieds noirs ça
c'est un mystérieux ipad ou à je
comprends pas ce qu'on attend encore
mais oui mais encore jamais on m'a dit
vous vous êtes breton jamais ça je peux
le jurer pourtant il ya pourtant il ya
des bretons il sombra et benjamin on me
l'a dit et en plus si tu es tu as si
c'est que sa chute est rude moi j'ai la
tête moyen un mois un mulet moi j'ai
connu quand génie d'avoir avec moi il
vient avaliser son frère et moi n'est
pas la tête moi j'ai la tête qu'on mène
dans le maine pour travail à paris et
j'aime les crêpes
j'adore les crêpes au grand marnier au
sucre à la confiture et les biscuits
aussi les bretons et j'aime les biscuits
les bretons ils aiment les biscuits à
wil et pourtant je les lui les biscuits
je les lui les bretons il est gelé l'ubs
ont fait pas sans moi mais j'aime les
traits chuter tu j'aime les biscuits
kenavo et toute la smala et jamais on
m'a dit vous vous êtes breton jamais à
peine on me voit magie où vous vous êtes
pieds noirs
mais comme mon équipe est d'ailleurs
encore un chinois
ça se reconnaît facilement y a il ya un
truc qu'on peut reconnaître chinois tous
les coups ça se voit comme le nez au
milieu du visage
si les pieds ils ont des petits pieds et
oui tandis que moi je suis du quart en
pro forma cause du football je jouais
libéraux quand on est descendu en 9e
division
sa défense est l'homme mais enfin et
puis à autre chose il ya autre chose en
fortran plus rencontre on peut
reconnaître un chinois vraiment à tous
les coups c'est qu'ils sont forts au
ping pong
ils sont champions du monde remarquait
déjà pour manger dans les baguettes
alors de tout petits sont entraînés un
grain de riz mbalakh tactile
alors dans mon comprennent pas pour un
chinois à la rigueur je l'admets mais
comment les types il faut pour deviner
que je suis pieds noirs ça c'est un
mystère mais la meilleure c'est quand
tout à l'heure pour venir je prends un
taxi je prends un taxi
j'étais en train de discuter avec le
chauffeur là j'étais justement en train
de lui dire que le compteur il allait
très vite et pourtant la voiture elle
aller doucement
et alors oui alors je lui faisais
remarquer sur coup là alors il me dit
mais vous vous n'est ce pas de là bas
jeudi 12 de finlande parce que je le
voyais venir
je croyais à venir l'arnaqueuse vas y je
dis non non non non je voulais dire vous
n'êtes pas de vous êtes à pied noir jo
je dis oui mais comment vous m'avez
reconnu ils me diront qu'on manque en
revanche quand on vous entend parler
alors un il suffit cela elle patin
couffin
c'est pas vrai [ __ ] relâche deviennent
dingues deviennent dingues et ça me dire
quand on entend quand on est attaqué
samedi 14 rebonds alors admettons
alors dans ces conditions comment ça se
fait à alger pendant trente ans que
j'habite et bab el oued
quand je parlais et je parle jamais un
chip il m'a dit une seule fois au vous
vous expliquez moi j'aime ça c'est
unique au monde ça c'est unique au monde